by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and i today am wearing
a wife beater is that the only term we
have available these days right
is it like a tank it's a tank top but
it's not a tank top this is commonly
referred to as a wife beater why are you
wearing a wife beater mark that's not in
your normal repertoire of clothing well
the thing is i did a sketch the other
day yes i'm a very important actor and
people invite me to do sketches all the
time for free and i say yes i can do
that because i make so much money and so
many other endeavors that it really
doesn't matter to me whether i get paid
for this little sketch or not in this
case
it's a guy named adam w he's got a lot
of subscribers on youtube puts out a lot
of sketch content i'm aware of him and
he's worked with people i know
and he was like what's up dude like
actually his assistant hit me this is
how big adam w is
he hit me up
to do a sketch via his assistant you
know you're dealing with a big-time
baller when somebody's like yo this is
so-and-so's assistant to schedule you in
it's like damn like i'm getting the
assistant treatment huh which you would
think almost would be condescending but
you're like no no i appreciate the fact
that this dude is so busy so focused
so in the zone that he can't handle all
these logistical issues because he's
busy being creative so
he's doing some branded content for old
spice
and i needed to show up in
non-branded gym attire which i don't
have any i don't have any tank tops they
don't have logos on them etc so i said
let me go to target and for the first
time in probably 10 years i'm gonna buy
a pack of these
wife beaters
so
uh turns out i look really good in them
i hate to break you know i remember oh
yeah this is why i would wear them in
high school i put them on they're
form-fitting they hug the waist
they cup the titties they look
incredible specifically i can't say for
you maybe you look bad on a wife beater
maybe you've got a gut and skinny arms i
don't know what's going on with your
body personally i hope that everybody
looking at this has the body that they
dream of
but even i don't have the body i dream
of it's just like really close to that
so
i decided you know what it's time to
reintroduce tire just like this
no labels
no logos
nothing flashy
just titty hugging action so
that's the backstory of how mark went to
target to buy undergarments guys last
time we did a podcast i was about like
right after we finished i went to go to
an orthopedic specialist to get my
shoulder looked at i forget how much
i've talked about
my shoulder on this podcast because
again i have cte and my cognition is
slowly declining each episode as casey's
pointed out i don't necessarily remember
what i said in each episode
five minutes ago i may have no idea what
is this show already up and running what
have i talked about so far i can't
totally be sure all i have is
guesstimates but i know at least mention
the fact that my shoulder is fat
and uh let's just say this i confirm
that it's even more [ __ ] than i
thought it was previously
i went in and i'll be honest here okay
like
this is
something that
i'm gonna get vulnerable over to try to
give you the actual emotions that i was
feeling when i got this diagnosis
because i went to the
specialist and thought this is finally
going to be the solution to the problem
that i have this chronic pain in my
shoulder i have these areas of weakness
and atrophy basically my whole right
side like my pec is a little bit smaller
in my shoulder this part and there's
like little strands where it's like oh
my rear deltoid is like just like just
that slice of muscle here and then like
the medial deltoid is fine and then you
know there's just all these little
issues like when you have a major
you know joint that does so many things
right it affects so many other things
and
i have just been powering through it all
these years and kind of working through
the pain because if it's not like
debilitating to the point of like i
can't raise my arm you know i'm gonna
prefer to be like
push through it don't be a [ __ ] yes
it's a dull ache or
whatever
you know pain if you can tolerate it
then it's totally fine right that's an
attitude i think a lot of guys take when
they're dealing with these chronic pain
issues that in my case stem from having
my shoulder dislocated
i even used the word subluxated because
i'd see other people get their shoulders
dislocated have you ever dislocated your
shoulder i have yeah actually i used i
initially did it playing basketball i
went and like swiped down on the ball
and dude was holding that mega hard and
my shoulder went and it was out and it
was like scary it didn't go back in for
a little while yeah and then it would
come out in my sleep all the time yeah
so and in the
that moment of like it comes out and
it's really painful and like put it back
in was that very dramatic like was it
like ah like that kind of thing yeah i
wasn't screaming but i said to my friend
i was like i'm scared yeah like it
wasn't going back in and it was all
dangly and wonky yeah and so i think
because i've seen people have that
happen and whenever like there's a i've
seen a shoulder dislocation it looks
more like that where it's like oh [ __ ]
but apparently i have really loose
shoulders like i can i don't know like i
used to think everybody could kind of do
this like i don't know if you see like
but i was like they kind of like my
shoulders can kind of roll out of the
socket anyway and they always have been
able to do that that creates a slightly
looser shoulder
and so like
i would experience dislocation but it
was like this painful and then it popped
back in but it wasn't like this oh it's
hurt and then i have to shove it back it
was like
you know well it's loose to begin with
but that doesn't mean it still can't be
damaged so over the years
um
you know what ends up happening is you
you wear away the labrum you know the
cartilage lining of the ball and socket
joint uh which wasn't totally confirmed
he was just speculating but i think you
need another we took an x-ray so you
need maybe need other types of imaging
to know exactly what's going on but it
for sure like doesn't feel good and as
smooth as the other one and what i'd
lift really heavy it just felt like oh
there's this dull ache afterwards it
kind of suggests like you know or
certain positions
that go like this to see like ah you get
the bone on bone feeling
that other people report from having
these degenerative
joint issues now
i'll just back up by saying i thought i
was going to go in here
and
find a solution and by the way shout out
shout out to my friend um
austin who
set this up he's a doctor from toronto
who i met online and he hooked me up
with his buddy from medical school who's
in orange he he my insurance didn't
cover the visit so he paid for it super
i mean come on dude
how generous are you and and these
people that i meet online that don't owe
me anything don't you know never met me
in person but still willing to do stuff
like that that's very touching in and of
itself because it's something i just
would have put off you know
and i was able to do the imaging right
there and get to the bottom of it now i
was expecting some sort of answer like
oh we found the little tiny thing that's
wrong and all we have to do is you know
put a scope in your shoulder and take
that out and then everything's gonna be
fine right and the only
impediment to my full use of my shoulder
would be having some sort of minor
arthroscopic surgery and my arm would be
in a sling for a couple weeks and then i
can go back to building it back up
per usual and really again the main
annoyance it was the pain but really
like the asymmetry i don't know if
you've ever had this but you're like
looking at them you're like [ __ ] like my
one side looks different and it's
annoying and just kind of you know if
you're bodybuilding you potentially
fixate on that so go in
get the images
uh he he does it from all angles and
then we put him up there and he's like
see right here you got these uh
these bone spurs right from the bones
rubbing together because all the
cartilage is gone like you develop these
little you know extra areas of bone i
guess on
on your shoulder so like inside you know
the socket and on the end of the humerus
um not good right
because that's years of like
causing you know un unnecessary friction
and stuff like that so you got bone
spurs and then
he said you have an arthritic shoulder
which i was into you know i don't know
even know how arthritis works i'm like
wait i don't even realize you know i
i just associate it with like
commercials for old people rubbing their
hands that's what it's like arthritis ah
it's like okay some sort of joint
inflammation i guess but um
yeah it makes sense because i have this
you know like chronic sort of pain in my
shoulder when i do things with it and
then
i think that pretty much covers it
um but
i guess it's like okay okay yeah sure
cool what's the solution right because
you can tell me whatever's wrong with my
shoulder but it's like and we can fix it
right
therein lies the issue because the first
thing he says is now we could go in
there and do a shoulder reconstruction
where you go in there and you shave off
the bone spurs and
you know you take out any loose [ __ ]
there and
yada yada and
you i don't know exactly what they do
but they essentially create stiffness
because the big issue is you have this
looseness in your joint when it's been
popping you know which again when you're
lifting super heavy you just want you
want a very stable shoulder and the
things that happen that undermine that
stability are the cause of this pain and
atrophy in certain muscles because you
just can't fire it
with the same sort of strength and
stability from certain angles
so he goes well we could do a shoulder
complete shoulder reconstruction which
also was kind of like well that's
intense right um
because i've had an acl reconstruction
and you know nine months
of
rehab to get back to normal
and so i was like okay cool
okay sounds intense but let's do it you
know
and then he's like well the only thing
is
in 15 years you're going to need a
shoulder replacement anyway
and i was like uh
like a shoulder replacement like they're
gonna like saw off the bone in my
shoulder and put metal into it
and i looked it up later it's actually
not as bad as i thought but in the
moment
it felt like he was diagnosing me with
cancer or something like i have you know
not to belittle cancer or or make light
of anybody's experience because
obviously these two are incomparable it
just felt like
i
was like looking out into my future and
had this one future in mind where it's
like i'm going to be 50 and 60 and be
lifting like totally normal like you
know with no restrictions whatsoever and
then in that moment i'm like
i'm going to have to give up the only
thing that brings me joy in life right
like i was thinking like legit like i
almost felt like crying which is not i
just don't you know and i'd be open
about like i do i cry about my cat
whatever i don't care
i can talk about the the ways in which i
cry i'm never gonna like be ashamed of
that but that was one of these moments
it just doesn't happen a lot but you
know and i suppress it but it's like
uh i really was sitting there feeling
like
it's not are you sure can you check
again
look at the x-rays one more time um
and so therein lies the problem is
you know he goes you can have the
shoulder reconstruction but when they
create that stiffness
which helps the stability of your joint
in the reconstruction
what it does is undermines your ability
to recover
from the
replacement later on because you really
like i actually have a really good range
of motion you know like this is
extremely painful but i can like i could
do a snatch it's just like in the latter
part of that range of motion it starts
to hurt a lot
and if you have a shoulder
reconstruction
you're not going to be able to do this
right for the sake of the stability so
you take all these things away which
makes the rehab harder when you have a
replacement and
like potentially
more likely to like something could go
wrong with just because when you're
shaving down bone then it's like there's
less bone there and it could like you
know because you can have this metal
thing in your [ __ ] arm and it could
break or you know like your the bone
could fracture whatever after that so it
increases the risk of
complications uh when you're doing
the
replacement in say 15 years so it's like
oh so that's not even on the table
i'm just gonna have to like wait until
it gets so bad that they have to saw you
know the bones in my arm and put a
[ __ ] bionic thing in there
so i had this moment where i was like
felt like crying felt like it was
pointless felt like i'd had hope this
entire time and went in and it was just
like all dashed however
my
mindset and i hope to impart this
on you because i do believe in this
approach
to bad news is just reframing it you
know i had one frame in mind that was
gonna like surgery is gonna fix it and i
was attached to that irrationally
and
just let myself really believe that
there was this easy fix involved without
any real information about you know what
exactly was gonna need to happen
after i had a few hours of pouting and
my little pity party i realized okay no
i can i can change the way i train i
don't have to give these things up i
looked up some videos online of
people training after having the
shoulder replacement it's actually
pretty remarkable
you know i don't know if you've known
anything about like these replacements
or you know but the thing is and i
actually train a guy who's gonna have a
hip replacement soon and it's like
you're in a lot of pain when you don't
have it
you might be limited to certain things
you can do
with a hip replacement but you're not in
pain you don't even mean like the pain
totally goes away so at least i have
that to look forward to and somehow
the hip seems a lot scary because
they're like sawing off your [ __ ]
femur
you know and just when you look at the
diagram the shoulder it's like oh it's
less than you're like they're still
doing a lot of stuff to it but it's it
doesn't look as intense so i reframed it
i'm like that's not a bad thing i still
have 15 years i can get as strong as
possible and really
he just made some minor suggestions
about how to change your training which
i'm going to have to do i really like
going to failure using heavy weights and
doing things like wide grip bench press
why because
my ego says well you can lift more when
you do y grip
or whatever it is but usually it's like
i'm going to say oh like i've noticed i
can do more when i do this and yana yana
and so i've just lifted like that for a
long period of time and
i know i'm going on and on about my
shoulder but let me just wrap this up
because this is part of you know what
i'm going to save the rest of it how i'm
going to adjust my training for a bro
science academy all right so we'll get
back to that just you watch uh
but we're going to
go into a couple more things for subful
so i can tell you about my weekend
because i'm going to set up some other
things too
so i went with uh brendan to the no
jumper podcast that was cool to me
out of 22 and see that set he's got a
lot of interesting uh
content he's sort of living the life are
you aware about him 22 right i'm not
okay so he runs this podcast called no
jumper it's kind of hip-hop themed um
and also themed towards like
getting like popular instagram thoughts
or
and i even hate using that word but it's
just like
the women promiscuous women on social
media who have only fans or do sort of
sexual publicity stunts like you know
i'm known for blowing all the dudes on
the lakers while they're in the nba
bubble you know whatever it is like
you'll have that girl on right that's
going in the teaser by the way that one
right there
i hope it does
now and then he also
he's got hit this girl
lane of the plug is her name and they
also shoot content for either patreon or
only fans whatever it is but like he'll
have a hot girl on who's like in porn
and then they both have a threesome with
her it's kind of like
like i think if most guys are being
honest they look at that and go like now
that's the life the dude's getting paid
like hey like i have this stable
relationship and it's like you mind if i
[ __ ] this super hot chick like on camera
and we can make money from it like
pretty sweet business model huh so
nothing but respect he was a really cool
guy his associates are all cool and i
just you know it's cool to be
to go you know see the behind the scenes
of a show that i actually watch
i also went uh oh my god i saw
another shop and friends show and aziz
ansari dropped in casey
and
uh
i'm a fan of his stand up
you know watch this specials and stuff
i've never seen him live before and he
did this bit
i'm not sure how organic it was because
obviously he's really good at stand-up
comedy and he could have made it seem
like it was off the cuff but i think the
intention was to make it seem like this
was an organic thing but i think the
first thing he said in the middle of the
set was like are there any interracial
couples here and
he looked out to the crowd and found one
and i think he asked the girl who is uh
not white if she used the n-word and
then he starts asking the guy how many
times in your life have you used the
n-word like in public and private
and it just got so awkward and so funny
because it's like you know he's like all
right like you know your first things
i've never used in my life like
and then it's like okay but like in
private you know like three times we're
talking ten times back and a million is
like like forcing the guy to like narrow
down a guesstimate of how many times
he's used the n-word you know in this uh
public space and it was just like
holy [ __ ] and he just kept pressing like
he pretended like back up he's like all
right so like three like 12 like we're
saying like between like nine and 12 and
may you know um
but it was just perfect timing
because of the joe rogan stuff which
we'll also get into
and it's like a little
you know it reminded me of the approach
that i want to explain when i think
about these things and try to have my
own opinion on them because that was a
take i've never heard before
like ask a random white person
like not yes or no do i use this be like
all right like you could say i'm never
going to use it again but like in your
life like how many times have you used
the unworn
and watching people squirm in response
to that is just
so painful but also so funny
last couple things i went to the super
bowl event with brendan
got to meet uh it was like this money
line event where he's sitting on a couch
podcasting with mike tyson
football player named brandon marshall
who's a giant i mean the dude played
wide receiver you aware of like i wasn't
totally aware of them because i stopped
playing football or watching football
but it's like oh this guy's a wide
receiver i'd be shocked if he was under
260 pounds like the guy just dwarfs me
and it's like oh you're the you're like
the skinniest like
position like the cliche of a of a wide
receiver so
you know it's always interesting to put
that in perspective like oh oh yeah yeah
that's that's why i didn't make it to
the nfl um
nothing was even trying okay
i could have if i wanted to and i was
stronger faster better at football had
better football intelligence and
started playing football at an earlier
age but like aside from that
uh oh and
we're gonna do a hater of the week based
on what happened here but like there was
i you know i always get bombarded with
this [ __ ] where it's like oh 40 40
people are telling dm'ing you the same
exact thing funny funny coincidence
wonder where that's coming from um
at some point during the super bowl
podcast brendan's sitting on the couch
he asked me to grab him a whiskey
because there's like a party in the
background and it's kind of you could
get up and mike tyson kept getting up
and like wandering in the crowd but it's
like you know it's a hassle right so
that's when we're gonna bring him a
drink
i come hand it to him and in the process
of trying to be slick and like not be on
camera i knock over
multiple plants
and so now i have to be like i'm like oh
[ __ ] like i'm you know i'm not going
to be like ah come clean this up like
you're going to see it on camera so i'm
like now i have to like go in and like
you know as inconspicuously as possible
which might not be possible to be
inconspicuous but i have to upright the
plants again that was the main
embarrassing thing
people are dming me all weekend like oh
i saw you hiding in the plants and
you're brendan's servant and like that's
why you're such a failed actress because
you have to work as brendan's interim
bringing him drinks for money and that's
your job and you'd suck at everything
and that's why you live in a tree you
know
like and everybody's repeating the same
exact [ __ ] i'm like oh no no like i was
there i know what happened i wasn't
hiding in a plant i knocked it over and
that's embarrassing but like you know
i'm not gonna like it wasn't like this
humiliating like oh my god you know
150 000 people watched the live stream
that i was on for four seconds knocking
over a plant
gotta kill myself
um so it's always funny the prem like
you know just again this
we'll analyze that in a second but i
just wanted to set that up that like
that was cool that was you know one
moment there where it's like ah it's
unfortunate i don't give a [ __ ] but then
when i see like 50 people fixating i'm
like oh oh that's still the best you got
huh is that i knocked over a plant
and you still have to misrepresent that
but it was cool to meet daniel cormier
super cool guy
not gonna lie when the first thing i
said to him what do you guys think it
was
i actually know because i heard it on
fire
[Laughter]
though let's hear it okay i went up to
him and said
uh you're talking to the marine county
athletic league wrestling champion 2001.
just
you know so funny to say the date okay i
know it's like the most decorated like
the best wrestling yeah this is two
championship level and so the caption i
posted on instagram was you know haters
will say this isn't a picture of two
elite wrestlers
so
i met him yes met him and
uh yuri prohaska that was kind of the
highlight
and i saw like it looked like yuri
prohaska the light heavyweight from the
ufc and he's got this hair and a bun
but i didn't want to yell it i didn't
want to buy yuri and it's like oh it's
just a guy with a man bun um but i did
talk to him he was super cool
and
my one interaction with mike tyson
because everybody
focuses on him and wants to take
pictures and i guess i kind of have this
ethical issue with like just going up to
somebody for a picture like i took a
picture with daniel cormier because it's
like
well i talked to you for five minutes so
now i feel like i'm justified and asking
for a picture but i'm not going to go up
to mike tyson like hey mike can i get a
picture thanks bye
but during the halftime show the best
halftime show of all time a lot of
people are saying
he's bopping his head as eminem is uh
you know doing the lose yourself
performance
and i say you like eminem and he's like
yeah
so we're best buds now wow
it's whatever dude
thank you so much
um
now the show can go on
it is not the computer will not die
today okay did you guys watch euphoria
at all yeah i'll come back okay you're
all cut up
god damn was that like
it's just
now
i'm a big fan of these types of
units of entertainment i like american
beauty i like little children i like
chad cult jen is an author who uh writes
a lot of this kind of like dark suburban
stories
i'm just a really big fan of like things
that are set in america and they're like
you know surface level this looks like a
normal high school life you know in a
suburb of a major american city or
something like that and then underneath
the surface
is the dark gritty realness and i think
they just do such an excellent job of
making things
uncomfortable and you're just sitting
there in the moment-to-moment tension
especially the last couple episodes
like you're in pain and i think that's
like a testament to like if you can make
me feel super uncomfortable but but i
can't look away like what a great piece
of storytelling and that's because i'm
like if it was just uncomfortable i'd
turn it off right but you're like i need
to know what's happening and also i'm
super uncomfortable this is so awkward
and you know the first thing that comes
to mind is like
when
the blonde chick gets called out for you
know roo's like yeah how long have you
been [ __ ] nate for and then the whole
room's just like oh you know when you're
sitting there like
what what are you talking about
that's one of many moments but the way
that they drew out all that tension and
the unexpectedness of how that woman
responded to like rue
saying you know i don't have the drugs
anymore and she's so calm i was like oh
my god like she's such a good actress
that way she's like
i haven't gotten angry in my entire life
you know whatever it was like i'm going
to sell you into child sex trafficking
but i'm not angry you know i didn't
especially want to tell me about it
um oh just
it's just quality you know it's not
about like the kids being in high school
or the drugs or the darkness it's just
it's high quality storytelling on every
level okay
all right let's take a little bit of a
break
from me talking endlessly about myself
and my issues to talk about some stuff
that i'm on right now as you're watching
this episode recently
i began experimenting with kratom it's
something that i've read about for a
couple years now and heard of the
benefits and had been eager to try and
then brendan came to me with a potential
sponsor in happy hippo kratom
and i thought this would be the perfect
opportunity to actually try it and give
it a go so before this podcast
i took some kratom and i got to tell you
it really works
as far as the the promise of what kratom
does as a sort of limitless pill as
something that fires up your brain as a
nootropic
brendan for example uses it every time
he goes on stage
i know a lot of people that use it as a
a focus enhancer and
i've been eager to try it and i wasn't
sure if it's going to work because i
take a lot of caffeine and you know i'm
always skeptical of products that sort
of you know claimed oh this could be
like outer or this could be it's better
than coffee you know
people make big claims rarely do they
deliver i feel
really
excited about the fact that this
delivers
on what it promises now the other thing
is too this is a reputable company right
kratom right now is kind of like this
you know what cbd used to be there's a
wild west out there and the quality
control over these products is something
you should consider very seriously when
you're buying kratom
this is a legit company highest quality
products you can trust that what is in
these products that you buy is what's on
the label okay so if you want high
quality kratom and you want to know
what's actually
in the packaging go with happy hippo so
if you use
promo code thickboy3c
at happyhippoherbles.comhappyhippos.com
use code thickboy3cs for 20 off
for life so you can use that as many
times you want i encourage you to try
this
like i've been legitimately impressed
and i'm gonna do more segments about
this in the future starting with next
week we're gonna do a deep dive on
kratom and i hope you try it out and see
what you think leave a comment if you
already use it and tell me how it has
affected your life and what you like to
do in it
back to the action
have i ranted enough is the entire
podcast me talking about my shoulder
that's okay let's get to some hey that
hurts haters will say mark looks like
his mouth was mauled by a chimpanzee and
then he became the first recipient of an
experimental procedure that used skin
from his own [ __ ] to reconstruct his
lips that's not true because i would
have known if i had that procedure right
so i can tell you from a first-hand
perspective
i didn't have that procedure done
you may be mistaking me for somebody
else who has [ __ ] lips haters will
say mark is the poster boy for what
happens when your parents give you too
much positive affirmation
do you think that's
that's true no i'm a good person right
100 percent yeah i'm in like i'm funny
right yeah right mom
um
haters will say mark got banned from his
local 24 hour fitness after management
received several complaints about him
staring at old guys dicks in the locker
room
that one they told me something else you
know but like you know is it my fault
that they change so slowly it's like
yeah
you know you you
wag that old man dick out for long
enough i'm gonna take a peek right but
if it's out for five minutes and i'm
looking for 30 seconds comparatively
that's not that long of a time if it was
only out for 30 seconds and i'm looking
the entire time i think then that's a
more legitimate grounds for complaints
but the fact is i was looking for only
10 of the time on average that that old
man's penis was out amongst other old
man penises but
you know it's not a sexual thing i'm
just fascinated by old man dicks
okay mark
haters will say mark's the kind of guy
who recently dry cleaned his high school
letterman jacket just in case an
upcoming occasion warrants it i don't
it is unnerving when people it's like
are you following me around or like did
you did somebody i know tell you about
that i don't know i'm not gonna think
about it like i'm just gonna acknowledge
the fact that i am a celebrity and
people are obsessed with what i dry
clean that's my takeaway oh goodness
gracious
another liver king member of the week
you know i was watching congratulations
the other week and i was very delighted
that chris delia is also uh obsessed
with the uh the liver king
and i don't mean obsessed like
pejoratively it's just he seems to be
fascinated by him and we had a little
exchange on instagram about how he's
you know our favorite influencer of all
time
okay this one says it's a picture of do
we know what this is from just so i can
set that up
oh
i know i probably should know like what
this still is but it's okay it's an
actress and she's like crying and eating
something through tears she does not
look like she's in a good place
the caption is liver queen pretending to
enjoy fermented goat [ __ ] and raw gazelle
labia on liver king's instagram
and she's saying this is good
um
now this is another liver king i'm
always going to try to bring a liver
king meme and a liver king something
else like a video that he posted but
this was i found interesting
and i'm going to say this guy's name i
do not
mean to call you out or like
mock you in any way because you are
expressing an opinion and i actually
want to be respectful
in
disagreeing with you knowing that you're
coming from a good place and i want to
expand this conversation but i have to
but when i first read it this was in the
comments of the last episode uh i did
sort of laugh to myself and i'll explain
why
so mike uh mike benoit says hey hey man
not a hater and i believe you
but brian johnson the liver king has
been my customer for several years
and that guy lives and breathes
everything he says now i'm not denying
that i'm not denying he lives the
ancestral tenets so that that and i try
to separate that criticism you know that
this dude
works out like a maniac he eats all the
stuff he says he eats he's out in the
sun he gets the cold he gets to sleep he
doesn't go on social media too much like
those things you know i like i think
he's got a good system my issue is with
when it comes to steroids and his
like skirting of the truth and he hasn't
said like i don't take steroids or i do
take steroids it's always some weird
kind of around you know uh skirting
around the issue and addressing it
indirectly which to me is sort of
uh
makes me think that he's hiding
something he just acts sort of guilty
but anyway this guy says
he is uh he is with he's
with my customer for years before social
media okay
maybe he meant he knows his customers
for years before social media he is a
weirdo animal
and he is i mean objectively he's a
weird kind of you know he's got some
quirks let's be honest he's a weirdo
animal i'll give you that but
it's definitely all natural in the
weirdest way possible now i don't know
what that qualifier like you're natural
in the weirdest way possible you know i
don't know exactly what that means but
it's like maybe he's saying it's
unexpectedly like i see what you're
saying that he doesn't look natural but
weirdly he is
by the way i sell powersports all those
off-road machines he he bought from me
so check out mike benoit and buy
something from him to make up for the
fact that i'm calling him out he says
party on way now again this guy is like
he's expressing his opinion he did it
respectfully and i think this is pretty
common that you see people
go no the rock's on steroids like he
says he isn't you know the rock works
out all the time like i've seen him i've
seen his work ethic you know i've seen
these bits of evidence that i take as
proof that he does not take steroids
however
i think you're being a little bit naive
my response to that was with all due
respect
you're out of your mind if you think
he's natural okay
maybe that's not respectful but that's
what i believe
you base that assertion on what his
claims or have you been randomly drug
testing him since you've known him
but could be fun to have you call in if
you want to do a little back and forth
on whether he's natural and maybe he'll
respond to this comment but
people often conflate this sort of like
he says he's not and i've seen him work
out those are not evidence of somebody
being natural you would literally have
to randomly drug test somebody and even
then i mean people get away with
doping all the time but we're not
talking about an athletic context i'm
not accusing him of cheating and he's
actually gone one of the ways he's
squirted around this direct denial is he
goes i've never cheated in my life and
it's like well we're not accusing you of
cheating
we're accusing you of omitting something
yeah you'd have to be an athlete to be
cheating he's right athlete he's a big
strong right yeah and so that's you know
it's one of these rhetorical bait and
switches where it's like i've never
cheated it's like but i i didn't say
cheating you said cheating and that
shifts the goal post over here when
that's not the accusation the accusation
is you're misrepresenting how you
attained the look of your physique which
is the look that people are responding
to and aiding you and going viral okay
so mike i want to hear back from you and
potentially we could even have a fun
little debate on the show um
you know
and i don't mean to condescend to people
like you don't know anything about
steroids but you do kind of have to come
from that place it's like well i'm not
saying i'm the world's foremost expert
on it but having taken them and known
many people who have there are certain
telltale signs that i use or that i that
i look for in making my determination
that maybe people aren't totally
aware of
because look i was [ __ ] naive too
when i was growing up i thought all the
guys in the muscle mags were natty
because they they wouldn't say anything
about it it's like well they don't talk
about steroids and they say that they're
using cell tech
and that's why they're 350 pounds at six
percent body fat in the off season it
works for me i mean the cognitive
dissonance there
it's it's very powerful in so many walks
of life but had i not had the direct
experience of putting steroids into my
body i wouldn't know what they look like
in other people's bodies
all right let's do a mark harley movie
of the week daniel rabone
is
so clutch when it comes to setting the
the funniest she does like sends me
stuff every week that it just cracks me
up this is my hair on
joe biden's face with my goatee on there
and uh i gotta say kind of
it makes me realize how ridiculous my
hair looks but at the same time it's not
like it looks bad on joe biden that's
what i'm saying i'm like biden should
grow it out let it let it go
yeah like i want to be though it looks
creepy but it's not totally creepy you
also did uh my face on
trump's face with my hair we'll do that
next week and then he this is a really
funny one he did uh you know i posted
this picture right here my face on snoop
dogg's body performing at the super bowl
haters will say this was the best that i
didn't deliver the best performance at a
super bowl of all time
and uh i gotta say i kind of look good
at snoop dogg i honestly look at an
image like that and i'm like i should
lose weight and look like here
because it just looks cool and closed
like i can't wear something like that
and just be like yeah like you know
skinny lanky dudes look really good
in clothing like if i don't wear the
right thing i just gonna look fat
right
so that's why i wear tank tops no it's
muscle under here i swear
i'm not just a big puffy marshmallow
cool stuff i saw on the internet this
week look at this meme right here now
somebody was like haters will say you
would you won't post a meme about 50
cents because he follows you and it is
true i'm very careful about
disrespecting 50 cent because he
it put a lot of money in my pocket and
gave me a big opportunity for which i am
forever grateful and actually have a
tremendous amount of respect for him so
that counters into that that factors in
when you're thinking about putting
something disrespectful like somebody
posted a meme where
it's like
uh you know uh bizarre from d12 hanging
upside down
you know yes 50 cent's gained some
weight over the years as most men do you
know over the course of 25 years as they
you know march towards middle age but he
still works out a lot looks good
but uh you know is he six percent body
fat like he used to be when he filmed
the original video for this no uh is it
is he thick enough to be this dude's
dick in a meme
yes and that is funny enough to warrant
me actually sharing that one and i feel
like it's not disrespectful
um
the other cool thing i saw on the
internet let's click on that link real
quick
oh my god this somebody sent me this and
it was just
perfect
when he wrote uncut
do you know what uncle john
uncut
okay we're gonna hear the first part
this is kanye's
[Music]
this is uh one of the girls from the
caller daddy podcast the former caller
daddy podcast i forget what her name is
no disrespect but it's alex or alexis or
something um she's interviewing this
girl who kanye west is dating right now
julia fox julia fox okay thank you thank
you casey
and
to refer to yourself as a muse it's just
one of those things where it's like oh
god like you gotta kind of let other
people say this is my muse you can't be
like i am a muse
and i am responsible for one of the
greatest movies that adam sandler's ever
been in because i was in the room while
my boyfriend was writing the script
whatever she's claiming it's just a very
you know it's like oh you're the muse
for this like dark tale of a you know
like a diamond dealer and and uh
betting gone wrong like uncut gems is a
fantastic movie and these are two of my
favorite directors of all time and i
love the movie they did before that with
uh robert pattinson have you seen that
yes good time good time yeah like
i like
out
i was stunned by it i'm like how is this
not like more talked about somebody had
to be like dude watch this watch this
watch this and this is so original
inventive and just intense and same
thing with uncut gems and so to hear
this girl and who knows like i'm not
saying that there's no truth to it
whatsoever but the conceit of saying
like something like that
and how she says it and this is so
because if you're in l.a you also know
this is how girls talk when i do like my
markeisha character and it's like like
i'm not doing this
without being rooted in reality that
women really talk like this and i love
it so let's hear it one more time
um
oh um
uncle john what is
that's uh like up speak right yes up
speak yeah
and also just taking the ending
milking it just milking it yeah
it's like so like casual and obvious
like
it isn't uncut gems i was there and i
was the muse it's i was like
[Music]
all right moving right along i want to
talk
hater of the week is everybody who kept
messaging me that i was hiding in the
bushes to give brendan
whiskey and again i point this out
because the pattern that i'll always
come back to is
the moment
you
tell me something that is objectively
false because i wasn't hiding the bushes
i knocked the bushes over there i was
yes
this is
uh you know a this is a graphic
representation of what i looked like
at the super bowl party disappearing
into the bushes but like if that's what
i was doing i would cop up to it so the
what i've just found over the course of
this last year is
it's similar to the age thing like guys
would be like you're hiding in a bush
and you're in your 40s and i'm like i'm
almost in my 40s but not quite like why
is that like pivotal to you dissing me
is like the moment a man turns 40 that's
somehow like they can't do anything and
they've failed in life if they're not a
billionaire um
but the fact is
i'm not and i'll admit to it but
the pattern of you just you take the
truth and you have to embellish it and
then you're done and i had this
realization casey that
you know
because i always tell peop you've lost
the moment you're coming at me and this
is why it's still fun for me to talk
about these haters because they all come
in these clusters and it's like oh
you're all saying the same exact thing
to me like you're in a cult
right there's no independent thought
there you you're animated by like a
directive it all comes at once and it's
like i can't even distinguish between
what two different people are saying
because you all sound the same what i
realized is when i used to debate
politics for example online you start
out with like the facts or you're trying
to be like well actually abortion's
bound because you know um you're taking
a stance that at least even though it
might come from a place of emotion
usually this discourse is kind of
uh we navigate it with facts and
counterpoints and points so you're kind
of going back and forth and addressing
each other's points directly and the
moment that somebody goes
yeah that's why you suck at your job and
you're ugly and it has nothing to do
with the conversation you're like oh why
i won because this guy's now you know
going through my facebook page and
making fun of my
you know appearance and profession and
family members and i go oh my god that's
where all these dudes are starting from
like they're starting there and it's
like well i've already won like i can
just have fun with this now because you
started at the place where most people
end when they lose a debate and they're
like
you know get corrected on some basic
fact and they have a meltdown and start
insulting your appearance because they
know
there's no way out of this right and so
oh you're that's what it is it's like
the conversation's already over you're
extending out that final portion where
you've been humiliated and your only
recourse is to
attack something
totally unrelated you know to any sort
of point or your life
and
that's what you keep having to repeat is
my appearance or i'm in the bushes or
i'm 50 years old and it's like oh but
huh something must have upset you
let's do a bro science academy
as i promised guys i'm in the business
of keeping promises not breaking them
mark how are you gonna address the fact
that your shoulder is gonna fall off in
five years well i'm going to make some
actual adjustments to how i lift and
i've already started doing this
basically
because
anything wide grip is just putting my
shoulder in a position
that's weaker it basically doesn't like
my pectoral fibers wouldn't fire in a
certain place and like you just if you
put your joints in a compromised
position that involves acute pain
your body simply can't fire those fibers
or contract in these positions and i
realized i was holding on to
certain approaches like the wide grip
bench press for example
wide group pull downs even
i noticed like i wouldn't get a pump in
a certain area be like you know like
this side would get pumped and like i'm
like ah you know i'm lifting the most
weight but i realize like something's
happening over on this side that i'm you
know would be in denial about but really
it was like i can tell something's not
working but my meathead ego side is like
no no go for the pr go for the heaviest
thing you could ever lift and that's
been fun and i've hit some pr's recently
but
i gotta let it all go
i really
had to make this conscious decision to
say all right i've had enough ego
lifting essentially
for my life and
so when i went to hit bench yesterday i
did incline normally i might go up to a
set of 315. i stayed at 225. i did close
grip
slow reps controlled on the bottom and
so now i'm you know doing three sets of
i think the most at it was 12 and then
maybe like
you know
10 and 8 or something like that to
relative failure but not quite like all
out because the other thing that happens
is when you go to failure
and this joint's weaker then you start
contorting the joint moves all these bad
things happen in that moment so like
i've talked about before you don't have
to train
to failure every time but what you do
have to do is add some volume add some
other elements that as the intensity and
proximity to failure goes down you can
up this time under tension holding the
bar right above your chest
really
focusing on the bar path
uh and consciously making that mind
muscle connection because you can
actually even though you're doing a
narrow grip for example i had one of the
best chest workouts i've ever had by
going lighter and going more narrow
two things that conventional wisdom
would dictate like go as heavy as
possible get these you know
the most you can lift on a barbell and
also
um you know go to failure and also
this is only going to work triceps well
it turns out
you know if your pet can only contract
when your arm is in this line um you're
going to get a better contraction so
ironically we've kind of been sold this
meme of like close grip stuff works your
triceps and doesn't work your pecs i got
a phenomenal chest workout from doing
all close grip stuff and that's how i'm
going to be using that in the future
okay
look i know we've been going on for a
long time
i want to get
to a couple more things okay
first of all i want to address the joe
rogan controversy with a little
something that's just for me okay
because we've heard all the angles on it
and i don't have anything to add per se
to the notion of should joe rogan be
canceled or not or the broader
conversation on uh you know
like cancel culture i have commentary on
cancer culture and even what that means
because i think people use the term in
different ways in different situations
but here's how i think about stuff like
this that might offer you insight into
the way that i approach some of these
ethical questions in order to not be
dogmatic or ideological we're talking
about a white guy using the n-word
which
um
you know the consensus is
it's not good ever and we as joe rogan
even put
it's sort of this one exception
to
the english language where we have these
rules around and it's like it's not for
you to use and yes black people can use
it but you can't the history is very
loaded almost more than any other racial
slur in america specifically so there's
all these exceptions to that rule but at
the end of the day you could sum it up
and say this is a a racial slur that
hurts people's feelings now
in order to define or look at sort of
the the
uh the
the nature of the ethical transgression
of joe rogan saying
the n word repeatedly
in the context of quoting other things
like rap lyrics for example or
discussing the word rather than
targeting it at an individual which i
think we can all agree you know is
below
you know targeting using the word to
attack somebody and if you keep going
down
increasing uh the severity of the use of
that word eventually you end up like you
know let's go to the extreme you're
using racial slurs to incite genocide
right that's like the farthest end of
the spectrum
well can we establish
another end of the spectrum where you go
there is no harm in
this if you continue to rob the context
and meaning of the word for example do
you know in chinese have you seen this
russell peters joke
or
okay
um in chinese sounds like the n word in
english
so you can have a chinese person
saying what to an american sounds like
the n word and they're basically saying
um right so that's one example where the
word is being spoken
but it's unintentional and has a
different meaning and context than
somebody who's a native english speaker
saying it totally benign it's benign
because you write so you go okay so the
word appearing from somebody's mouth
there are considerations to go like does
that person know what it means if they
don't is it a different language is it
you know so all these things where you
can say okay that's that's below joe
rogan because we can't even have a
debate about whether that person's
racist because they meant something
totally different another thing you
might say what's one step below what joe
rogan did sort of objectively is
what if he was on the podcast and he
admitted later that he thought the word
right
in that moment we wouldn't think that he
hurt
any
buddy
had he kept that to himself but that's
an example of something where the word
pops up it's not spoken but i think we
can agree that having the thought
doesn't harm anybody's feelings and
therefore is not an ethical
transgression between those two things
of of thinking a word or having a
similar sounding word in chinese spoken
by somebody who doesn't know english and
all the way to uh you know using racial
stories to incite genocide you have to
think for yourself about where joe
rogan's transgression lies on that
spectrum
if you're ideological or dogmatic or
have this approach that
every use of any racial slur is always
the same despite the context
well then all of these things would have
the same ethical value right so i
encourage you to create scenarios and
thought experiments and go okay
you know is it a one or is it a ten is
it a two is it a seven it's somewhere on
there and you can act
accordingly right you can
decide for yourself by imagining
scenarios that are more severe and less
severe
and
confidently come to your own conclusions
about
what is the the degree to which this
person
was wrong right and comparatively
uh you know to other transgressions that
other people have made where does that
fit in
and
what should be the recourse for this is
an apology
sufficient is he sincere etc all those
things you can take into consideration
and
you're doing this because why because
other people will try to get you to not
do that right they're going to try to
get you to accept like no no this is the
rule always and it doesn't matter
what the context was said it doesn't
matter if you're manipulating something
to make it seem worse by robbing it of
its context and that is a part of
canceled culture or specifically attacks
on comedians
it's dependent on robbing a joke of its
context because even if you're in a club
and you tell an edgy joke and people are
laughing well that was an effective joke
if you remove the context of the club in
the audience
well it might seem totally different
but
this is
the nature of people attempting to get
others in trouble for jokes or words or
whatever it starts with robbing the
context so put the context back in
think about where it is on the spectrum
with other transgressions around it and
that's its own context and all of a
sudden you are hello logical
that's the name of the segment i forgot
to say but it's like dude we're so
logical here and just like so smart this
is crazy and just
damn dude okay
let's do it this way we can't have nice
gyms alright let's just finish things
off here
okay this dude's scooping pre-workout
dry scooping and this is what you get oh
he dropped it all on the floor
oh because he was trying to catch his
headphones something like yeah wait i
didn't catch that at first
and he's like i gotta catch my
headphones and
aggressively throws the
and i'd say hey that's what you get man
that's what you get for dry scooping and
pre-workout i do not know of any reason
that you would dry scoop pre-workout
it's just stupid don't do it don't take
pre-workout don't do anything but go to
the gym and lift
and that guy that's like 20 bucks down
the drain i know it's not a lot of money
but i just you know i enjoyed seeing
that where it's like not only does you
have to suffer through that humiliation
but then it's like
you're sitting in a pile of pre-workout
powder and kind of your responsibility
to clean it up right so you got to like
yeah let me get a paper to eight paper
towels and just
yeah all right yeah i spilled the whole
the whole canister
it's on the floor
all right this dude i thought was funny
goes up and another reason to like not
get all pumped up before you do big
lifts is like there's no point this
doesn't help you concentrate you're
hopping and the smacking and the jumping
up and down none of those things help
this guy lift properly because he
immediately fails
in a way i've never seen before where
the bar like grabs his shoulders see me
it's like you know did somebody put uh
you know duct tape on those on the bar
that seemingly like
gripped his shirt and it's like somebody
like yanked him backwards with this
right
it's just i've never seen anybody fail
that way but clearly
something went wrong and it's because
yeah you're jumping up and down instead
of looking at the bar and focusing on
your setup dude you don't need to jump
up and down just do the [ __ ] lift and
did he do like smelling salts before
it wouldn't surprise me but all that
stuff i'm like dude just like do a good
rap you know you're doing everything but
focusing on the fact that you have to
get into the bar and take two steps
backward and then do a squat all right
what's the last one we got this guy he's
got five plates on a smith machine he's
got
uh like a slingshot bench assist thing
going on he's got a belt he's got
toothpick lugs he's not built whatsoever
he's doing this huge setup he's also
wearing work boots and jeans seemingly
but it's like it's all this
contradictory stuff it's like you know
you're in a smith machine putting on
five plates you're using a slingshot but
you know you don't look like you can
bench more than one plate at a time you
have all this equipment but you don't
have like
gym shoes
right i'm into it i'm
i don't know this is the first one where
i'm like you know
right i like it like and not and not
even to say that there isn't any sort of
benefit to this because like if you're
doing heavy negatives like that could
work but just
like what's the plan here you just want
to go up and go like i want to interview
these people because i go like there
must be some sort of mental illness
right even this is like 10 it's like
you're 10
just
totally you know delusions of grandeur
or whatever like did you think you were
gonna lift the weight do you not realize
that you look so stupid like you know
sure don't care what people think but at
the same time when you're in a gym doing
this like
everybody in the gym thinks you're
mentally ill so is that a risk you're
willing to take like you know and for
what it'd be one thing if it's like
people think i'm crazy because i
invested in this cryptocurrency that
took off and now i'm a billionaire but
it's like people think i'm crazy because
i put five plates uh on a smith machine
bench press covered myself uh with a
bench suit and a belt and wore black
boots and then failed on it
and almost broke my neck you know like
if it wasn't for the
the stoppers there the guy would have
snapped himself in half right and then
he has to crawl out from underneath it i
just want to go like was that worth it
is this something you're doing on the
regular do you realize this is damaging
your reputation do you realize that
people won't talk to you because you
look like a crazy person and that you're
not actually gaining any muscle again
you're always watching these people
going you know
is this
is this working because you don't
you don't look strong right so have you
like what were the other programs that
you looked into before deciding on this
one before deciding i'm going to put
every plate that i can grab on a smith
machine bench press and just let it
crush me
right that's
that's the strategy and somebody's
filling him out and though but i don't
know i just like i want to start
interviewing these people is what i'm
saying i want to start getting the crazy
people i want to find them and track
them down about get me in contact with
this person because i want to talk to i
want to go give me your mindset give me
your thought process i want to know
where things went wrong i want to know
if you've been diagnosed with
schizophrenia i want to know if you've
been diagnosed with bipolar and you're
having a manic episode of the gym that
makes you think you can bench press 500
pounds when you can probably barely do
20 push-ups okay i want to know were you
abused as a child i want to know were
you also given too much positive
affirmation as a kid and now all of a
sudden you set up unrealistic
expectations for yourself to the point
where everything you do ends up in a
failure and that's why you're in la
serving drinks to bread and shop like a
personal service it's okay mark
[ __ ] yeah um
let's cut all that out okay